the stars were also making their way to
New York City for the Tribeca Film
Festival starting with Oscar winner and
new Bond villain Rami Malek who's
gearing up to say goodbye to his mr.
robot it has been a very emotional
season thus far but it's exceptionally
difficult this season knowing it's
coming to an end it's really bittersweet
as Rami wraps up filming the fourth and
final season of the USA Network drama
he's crediting the role with catapulting
his career and landing him an Oscar I
wouldn't have got the the role of
Freddie Mercury and Bohemian Rhapsody if
it wasn't for this show this seemed to
propel me into a different space up next
for Rami playing James Bond's new
nemesis I am over the moon about it the
film festival also celebrated some major
Hollywood milestones the cast of spinal
tap reunited to mark its 35th
anniversary the Simpsons hit 30 years
that's more than 650 episodes and it's
been 25 years since the finale of In
Living Color the show that kicked off
the careers of JLo Jim Carrey and Jamie
Foxx so could we ever get a reboot I
think we did it and we did it at such a
high level that we need to just let that
sit here's what I say
I wouldn't save so much a reboot but I
like to come together and throw one last
big bash we can't remember our lives
[Music]
[Applause]